derrière ces portes dans ce tunnel du
petit train un chapitre de l'histoire de
la Réunion ces pages ne sont pas encore
totalement déchirés mais sérieusement
abîmé comme cet autorail des années
49-50 qui meurt de faire du surplace et
que une quinzaine de mille euros on peut
refaire sortir entièrement oui 120
œuvre sans compter la main d'oeuvre
Gérard Chotard avec d'autres passionnés
a déjà ressuscité le titre train dans
les années 80 aujourd'hui l'homme est
pessimiste alors on y a cru pendant 35
ans on a un petit peu le moral dans les
godasses on va pas se cacher
un pont au mauvais état empêche les
voitures et autorail d'arriver même
jusqu'à la gare de la Grande Chaloupe
pour l'entretien où les réparations par
exemple il y a aussi une interdiction de
circuler dans le tunnel côté possession
long de 4 km à cause de la présence de
sa langage on l'avait dit il serait bien
qu'il soit à la poubelle comme si on en
parlera plus mais la principale embuche
est ailleurs la loco vapeur elle elle
est au patrimoine elle est inscrite et
les auto monnaiements historiques selon
Yvette duchman qui a lancé une pétition
pour sauver le petit train il manque
d'abord une volonté politique et on veut
travailler avec nos élus et les
institutions qui sont concernées sont la
Région le Département en haut lieu les
intercommunalités si Nord et TCO les
deux communes Saint-Denis et la
possession encore une fois nous ne s'est
bénévoles et nous y a notre pays et nous
veut que notre pays
la pétition lancée il y a quelques jours
à tout de suite séduit Alexandre Dupuy
auteur de plusieurs films sur le titre
patrimoine et c'est que ce soit bâti ou
roulant c'est quelque chose qui est
important c'est que on doit préserver le
patrimoine on doit presser notre
richesse voilà et c'est nous alors que
comme on dit tu es un patrimoine
exceptionnel il a pas d'autres
patrimoine comme ça vous allez dans un
musée il y a il y a une histoire ici en
même temps vous avez le côté ludique
faites venir une classe de de je sais
pas une place de maternelle ou une place
de j'ai pas de CM1 par exemple CM2 vous
les faites venir ici vous allez voir
comment ils vont sortir ils vont sortir
avec la banane il y a pas de problème le
Titre 1 devait selon les déclarations du
gouverneur en 1882 renouveler la face du
pays aujourd'hui c'est le pays qui
semble se voiler la face refusant de
voir la nécessité de continuer à faire
vivre ce patrimoine